how we start listening to our own truth  is  by getting uncomfortable and embracing  it being willing to  feel afraid fear is a super freaking  healthy human emotion the unhealthy part  is trying to escape it but when someone  is  brave they're not looking to avoid fear  like okay like i'll do what you said  because like it doesn't make sense to me  but like  like it'd be really scary to do  something else and like face social  ridicule  if i'm doing the thing that i'm afraid  of that fear  will intensify and you know what i'm  willing to feel those feelings  renee brown she has a beautiful quote  which i love  and it's he or she who's willing to be  the most  uncomfortable is not only the bravest  but rises the highest